[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
die zubereitung für eine leckere süß
saurer soße
nachdem ihr dieses rezept ausprobiert
habt werdet ihr euch mit sicherheit
keine süß saurer soße mehr kaufen
wir benötigen folgende zutaten etwas öl
ein wenig saft ich habe mich für
ananassaft entschieden außerdem
leitungswasser und speisestärke
sojasauce ketchup und tomatenmark ein
wenig essig honig ingwer und knoblauch
die habe ich bereits fein geschnitten
außerdem etwas zitronensaft und wer mag
noch ein paar ananas stücke in einem
topf wird das öl erhitzt und
anschließend knoblauch und ingwer kurz
angedünstet ich habe mich für rapsöl
entschieden ihr könntet auch genausogut
sonnenblumenöl oder sesamöl verwenden
[Musik]
nach wenigen sekunden dem wir schon das
tomatenmark mit hinzu dass entfaltet
dann auch noch mal richtig schöne
röstaromen der ketchup kommt an der
stelle auch schon mit hinzu und dann
wird das alles schön miteinander
verrührt nun kommen nach und nach die
weiteren zutaten mit hinzu hier habe ich
bereits es sich hinzu gegeben und
anschließend die sojasauce anschließend
auch den anders saft ihr könnt an der
stelle auch jeden anderen süßen saft
neben orangensaft oder multivitaminsaft
würden auch gut passen sie allerdings
ananasscheiben aus der dose verwendet
dann könnt ihr an der stelle auch den
ananassaft aus der konservendose nehmen
anschließend den honig noch mit
hinzugeben und das ganze gut miteinander
verrühren
nun gebe ich noch einen kleinen spritzer
zitronensaft mit hinzu das gibt noch mal
eine richtig schöne säure und
anschließend lassen wir das einmal
aufkochen
[Musik]
nebenbei bereite ich mir schon mal die
speisestärke zu hier gebe ich ein wenig
leitungswasser mit zur speisestärke und
verrührt das klümpchen frei
damit dies anschließend mit in den topf
geben kann
[Musik]
nachdem die speisestärke unter ständigem
rühren eingearbeitet wurde lassen wir
die soße noch einmal aufkochen damit sie
eindecken kann
[Musik]
zu guter letzt geben wir noch ananas
stücke mit hinzu einfach so viele wie am
liebsten mögt somit ist unsere süß
saurer soße auch schon fertig und so
lange hat die zubereitung gar nicht
gedauert
ihr könnt die süß saurer soße jetzt als
dip servieren neben frühlingsrollen oder
anderen asiatischen leckereien
[Musik]
dieses sommers hose habe ich persönlich
für gebratene asiatische nudeln
verwendet das video verlinkt ich euch
direkt im anschluss und dann freue ich
mich wenn ihr beim nächsten mal auch
wieder dabei sein
[Musik]